hey top 975 blazing today's hottest
music bootleg keV on your radio live in
studio right now fresh from the b.e.t
Awards freshman abiti Awards big show
yeah boy I think of it a round of
applause you're too kind hey man is kind
of crazy cuz like a lot of the newer um
cuz you're technically a new artist
right right um a lot of the newer
artists gotta perform at the pre the
pre-award show you got the an acting
award show it was crazy man i was
performing on a pre-show and then they
just bumped me up to the regular don't
worry man you know what it was it was
the blue blazer it was the blue plays
right yeah man it was we got it yeah
just love my last man I love that song
so much epic songs anthem man yeah and
it was great cuz my arm comes out like
now yeah tomorrow yeah it comes out
tomorrow hey I've been waiting my whole
life for that day yeah I gotta ask you
the album a lot of people a lot of
people would I got big sean's I was
never coming out yeah the delay was
crazy yeah and it's came on this is
finally here you finally got that hit
record uh how's it feel hey man if it
was great man you know I just remember
when my high school teacher told me I
was throwing my life away not going to
college tell me I'm stupid you turn down
the scholarship right Scottish using the
same teacher wants me to come back and
speak up hahaha that's tight you know
I'm not bragging about it I'm just
saying I'm just saying man whenever you
follow your heart do what you love to do
man you always end up in the right place
you never want to be 60 70 years old
what she woulda coulda shoulda did
something man so you know that's how I
live yes I do it no um you of course
Kanye West signed you yeah I know the
story on how you linked up ocana how did
you like how did that how have the first
meeting with Tanya had no similar to a
station like this man I used to go there
every Friday rap for him he's good at
every Friday and it was a show called
there friday night cypher there yeah and
on a friday night sight for him seize
the battle each other and wherever when
win the battles would get the rap like a
verse on air every friday night so i was
like the best promotion ever so i did it
every friday soon as I turn 60
to drive me and my best friend and I'm
we did it for like a year straight and
got a good relationship with the station
some for my junior to senior year going
to high school on I was cashing 120
dollar segments cuz I was a telemarketer
that shows whack so I remember being in
the bank and my homie Tom called me and
Tom was like y'all you listening to the
radio I'm like nah what's up he's like
man fo kind he had the station yo man if
you got on their rap for him he'll sign
you cuz I'm like man you sound dumb as
hell and 17 seconds later I was like man
that's a great idea likes trying to left
the bank without cash in my check went
home and grabbed a CD I have a son
around high school smashed to the
station since that show us every friday
this was saturday morning so i walked
right back in there and they let me in
yes they knew me yeah and I lied us and
I left my phone in the back offices so
they let me in the back you know what
I'm saying um then I went into the
backpack we're cayenne and fools with
zach i passed a security guard his road
manager shook his hand and on I was like
yo man I'm inspiring MC can I rap for
you he's like man I gotta go he said
only time yeah Lana ride to school
listening to you my hero man just let me
spit for you he's like alright man you
got 16 bars while we were walking out
the station man but you gotta go right
now go so I was like freestyle and makes
her like riddens mixer just like you
know you're in atlanta was just like in
a moment type of thing so we got to the
entrance / exit at the station and he
stopped and I could tell he was feeling
it cuz he was bobbing his head and then
he was like I live and he was like oh
snaps our ocean no I'm like oh you know
I'm he was my favorite rappers yeah I
was nervous as hell I was just rapping
towards the ground trying not to mess up
and that 16 bars ended up turning in
like 10 minutes man and I gave him my CD
he's on my listen to this right now and
that was the initial contact man but
even after that it took years and years
and years when i gave up everything man
everything just for the idea being
sienten not even for sure right and it
off came through Ben and I work my ass
off finally you have
now so much free music man yeah you know
yeah man you know the three free
mixtapes it everyone's like I another
pic charming take once I'm coming out oh
yeah exactly man and the thing is if you
pay attention to all the new artist man
especially from like just even look at
the freshman 10 there's been like the
last few years it's like 31 new artist
man it's only been like five or six of
them to put that out better made it yes
so it's a hell of an honor to be one of
those five or six or seven people man
you know me and wigs are like probably
the only ones from our cover and just
like other artists is so many other
artists who aren't even on the radar
like you who just been grindin man so
I'm I'm happy as hell man you know my
grandma's happy my mom is happy my mom's
here with me actually oh hey mom oh
that's what say I flew my mom my dad my
brother you know all my best friends man
cuz my album comes out now tonight at
midnight yes so what do you do it where
you do anything tonight X well to
celebrate you haven't I think we're
gonna be partying but man I'm gonna just
have a great time and it doesn't matter
if I made my hotel room in the club
whatever I'm man I'm gonna just be with
the people I love man and just sit and
you know just think about it like man
this is like some day that I thought
would almost never come and it's here
and the album is dope man oh thank you
I'm going to ask you Kanye did there's
no Kanye production on the album yeah he
did a couple tracks for me man we did a
few book sample clearance came into play
that was wack as hell and then we wanted
to save one so that was like one thing I
looked at the tracklist and I was like
but what was new bone was no ID produced
one out here he did the most of it man
so it has that that's just as good yeah
yeah you know it's tight man it's tight
that I could graduate you know from just
doing mixtapes are doing albums two min
I'm gonna keep the mixtapes coming cuz
mixtapes are way more armin right when
you do a commercial release you have to
have songs that you can commercially
release right and now i have to say it's
like a big fan of yours i was a little
disappointed there wasn't a mike mike
posner class Mike Posner was originally
on the song what goes around comes
around
and then something happened on the way I
have my words my haha yeah come on but
that's but definitely i'm gonna be on my
posters next album he's gonna be on mine
and I beauty of it all is that hey man
we're gonna do more than one hour cuz
ya'll kind of came up the other so yeah
most definitely must follow me what's
your favorite song an album my favorite
song on the album is probably mom my
memories even when I was on my mixtape
memories part 2 just for like the
message that has manly when you look
back on life while you have is the best
memories that adds so much more those
are two songs are a real personal i
really like high Wiz Khalifa on it and
Chitty Bang I really like don't some you
love me he not got a couple yeah it's a
great album is a great album all right
we're gonna play your joint right now
this is the join did you know got the
album out yeah there's a I got mom's the
one that broke finally yeah man it's
number one rap song in a country right
now are you are you down to kick some
bars for us oh man you bout to put some
stuff on I was no worry ladies come back
right down to kick some bars yeah well
you know you gonna put me on the spot
all right there in his Big Show Live is
studio let's get into in my last inside